the House of Representatives and the U.S  Senate are both well to the right they  are much more conservative than the  American people if you pull the U.S  Senate on their views on abortion they  are well to the right of the American  people as one example another way in  which Congress doesn't reflect modern  America according to a new Pew study is  that the House of Representatives the  Congress in general is way more  Christian than the American people even  though nearly 3 in 10 Americans claim no  religious affiliation writes PBS about  the Pew study only two of the 534  incoming members of Congress identify as  no religion 88 percent of Congress  identifies as Christian but only 63  percent of American adults identify as  Christians so this is yet another way in  which Congress is not reflective of  America big picture